[Music]
the recent shooting at a school in
america will be something you'll have
heard about and of course it's really
upsetting
we all have a right to go to school and
not to have to worry about our safety
it's highly unlikely that gun violence
would ever be a problem in the uk
because we have very strict controls
over who can own a gun and what it can
be used for
we've got hold of fyi psychologist
laverne for more advice hi laverne hi
there so when we do see news like this
that is really upsetting what do you
think the best ways are to try and get
through it well i think that it's really
important that everybody recognizes that
they're going to have a slightly
different response and that's okay but
if you have found it upsetting then i
think it's really important you do the
things that can be helpful so that might
be talking to adults so for example your
parents or your friends but really what
we want young people to do is to make
sure they take care of themselves and
one way to do that is to make sure you
get your news from a new source that you
really do trust so for example like fyi
and helps you understand the facts
so some of us go on holiday to america
or have friends and family there and are
feeling quite anxious what would you say
about that you know when we get a shock
we have to think well is this something
that happens a lot and actually in
actual fact these things do not happen
as often as perhaps our brains might
make us feel and then i think as you
think sort of more slowly through your
responses then you can get back to a
place where you can sort of trust your
accuracy and think well actually no
going on holiday to america is something
i'm looking forward to i don't need to
be worried about this and then in turn
thinking about family and friends there
that actually are living their lives
very very well because these events are
not very common they're very rare well
that's really great advice thank you so
much for speaking to us that's great
nice to see you again